غرات وقصف لعشره ايام استهدف مناطق واسعه
في شمال العراق وسوريا بدا بوقت الحساب
كما اسمته وزاره الدفاع التركيه مع
اعلانها عمليه المخلب السيف في العشرين من
نوفمبر لكن التراجع عن نسبيا للقذف
التركيه المكثف له حظ خلال الاسبوع الماضي
لكن عمليه عسكريه بريه وشيكا يصفها
الاتراك بالهجوم الذي مهما اعطى مهلا لانه
لا مفر منه بشكل نهائي لتبرزه التساؤلات
حول من يعطي الضوء الاخضر لانقره في شن
عملياتها على تلك الاراضي او بشكل ادى من
يؤثر على قراراتها حينما شنت تركيا هذه
العمليه كانت ذارعتها تفجير اسطنبول
الدمويه في منتصف في نوفمبر والمخلب السيف
ما هو الا التكشير عن انياب تركيا طب اي
شيء يمسه امنه خمسه و80 مليون مدني على ما
اسمته هجوما غادرا كانت قد اتهم في ذاك
الاعتداء كل من حزب العمال الكردستاني
والقوات الكرديه في سوريا بالوقوف خلفه
اشتد القصف على الشمال السوري في الربع
الاخير من نوفمبر وشمل عده مناطق ابرزها
عين العرب كوباني وترفعه والمالكيه هنا
اتت امريكا وعبرت عن مخاوفها على لسان
وزاره الدفاع البنتاجون وقالت ان الضربات
الجويه هدد سلامه الامريكيين الموجودين
هناك وكذلك ابدت قلقها حول تقليد القضاء
على داعش اليوم حضر المبعوث الامريكي
لشؤون شمال شرق سوريا
على تلك المناطق قائلا ان واشنطن لم تمنح
انقره الضوء الاخضر لذلك
[موسيقى]
اذا هو تهديد وانا
لم يكن الاول سبقه اقتحام قبل ثلاثه اعوام
يتزمن مع خشيه من طعنه في ظهر قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه فعلى حد تعبير قائدهم مظلوم
عبد فانهم قلقون من خذلان قد يكسر امال
قصد بامريكا كما فعلت سابقا في عهد الرئيس
السابق دون ترامب عام 2019 حينما التزم
الصمت ولم يقف ضد تركيا عبر عبدي ايضا عن
مخاوفه فحكايه زعزعت الثقه بين الغرب
واشنطن بالنسبه للاكراد لم تكن مره ولا
مرتين بل سبع مرات خلال قرن باكمله لكنهم
مع اداره الرئيس يلتمسون املا ولو كان ضئي
لنا في ادارهته بوعودها وبالتزاماتها والا
تسمح لتركيا بالقيام باي عمليه قد يكون
الضغط عليها سواء من روسيا او امريكا
بالتراجع الملحوظ عن القذف لاسيما وان
انقره قامت بخروقات لتفاهمات كانت اجرتها
معهما وعن محاربه داعش قال عبدي انهم لم
يتخلوا عن ذلك مع التحالف لكنهم منشغلون
بالتصدي بسبب الاوضاع الامنيه وبما انه
تحسن قليلا عاده تعاون المشتركه وشدد عبدي
في حواره على ان علاقه للاكراد بتفجير
اسطنبول كما زعموا بانهم يملكون ادله لم
يقبلوا ان يكشفوها لاحد فهذه عاداتهم لا
يحبون التعاون مع احدا ولم يعطوا اي
معلومه حقيقيه تدين الاكراد حتى للجانب
الامريكي فهم على حد التعبير عبدي يعطونا
المعلومات عبر طرف واحد الا وهو الاعلام
مضيفا انهم جمعوا كل التصريحات الاعلاميه
وبشر وتحقيقات تبرئهم من كل ذلك بحسبي ما
توصلوا اليه الاشخاص الذين قدموا الاتراك
واسمائهم ق منهم من مدن كانت مع داعش
والبنت التي نفذت العمليه قامت قبلها
بفتره قصيره بزيارات عده الى عفرين حيث
يقيم اخوها وعمها وعدد من افراد عائلتها
هنا مربط الفرس في عفرين ليست تحت سيطره
الاكراد وانما الاتراك بقياده ما يسمى
الجيش الوطني لذا واجه عبد التهاما ضنيا
لتركيا فان تفجير اسطنبول له علاقه
بالمناطق المحتله من قبلهم حيث ان قسما من
المتفجرات اتى من جرابلس
[موسيقى]
اذا خبراء سياسيون اشاروا الى ان
المفاوضات التي تجريها انقره مع واشنطن
وموسكو حاليا ليست لوقف العمليه وانما
للحصول على المزيد من الضمانات لحمايه
الحدود التركيه ما يعني ان تركيا قد لا
تابه بموافقه امريكا في حين كان لمحللين
اخرين راي مختلف معتبرين ان التهديدات
التركيه تطلق منذ اشهر لكنها في الواقع لن
تنفذ باي شيء على الارض بل انها تصاعد
لهجتها لترفع سقفه مطالبها ثم تتراجع ولم
تتلقى تركيا حتى الان ايرد من الولايات
المتحده لكن بعض المصادر المحت الى ان
واشنطن اقترحت اعاده هيكله قوه سوريا
ديمقراطيه ومنح دور اكبر للمكون العرب في
اداره منبج وتل رفعت وعين العرب اما جانب
الروسي الى حد ما يبدو مع شروط تركيا لكنه
وضع شروطا تتعلق بالملف الاوكراني مقابل
تقديم تنازلات ميدانيه وسياسيه في سوريا
حيث عرضت موسكو رفع الغطاء عن منطقه
الشهباء في ريف حلب وعين العرب لتسهيل
دخول القوات التركيه اليهما لتبقى
التوقعات ترجح ان تركيا قد تطلق عمليات
محدوده مع اصرار على وجود منطقه امنه على
طول الحدود بينهما او بينها وبين سوريا